يو يو أوتش يوسو
أهلاً
قفزة سعيدة مذهلة لا تستطيع ذلك
لا توصف
ما عدا الكلام فقط
الحمد لله الحمد لله لأنه دعنا
من خلال قوتك يمكنني الوصول إلى هنا
[موسيقى]
ها هو
ما هو اسم نذهب للحج
من خلال استقبال جزء التفويض من
والدينا المتوفين
[موسيقى]
رقم
السفر عبء بالرغم من ذلك
يا له من رعب
[موسيقى]
تلمس الانتظار
لقد مرت عقود على أمل
يمكن أن يغادر في المستقبل
من خلال تعظيم عدد الحصص
في إندونيسيا خاصة المعينين
أو وافقت عليها الحكومة
المملكة العربية السعودية
هذا الكوكب ، من العار أن يحرس الاسم
سوف تحصل على الحصة النسبية بذلك
إذا لم يتم استيفاء الحصة ، يمكنك ذلك
سلمت إلى إندونيسيا بذلك
سوف marpen سطح السفينة قائمة الانتظار أو
قائمة انتظار لمزيد من الحجاج الإندونيسيين
[موسيقى]
مفجع ولكن نأمل
السياسات الصادرة في
هذا يكفي لهذا العام مع أطيب التمنيات مرحباً
في العام المقبل سيتم افتتاحه بالكامل
لذلك لم يعد هناك حد للسن بعد الآن
يوم من المال لا بد لي من
ما رأيك في ذلك
كل شيء يجب أن أذهب Jagat من خلال آه
قرر الله أن علي أن أذهب
الحج الى